bonsoir messieurs merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france arnaud benedetti
je m'adresse aux communicants vous êtes
emmanuel macron avait promis de fixer le
cap dans la crise sanitaire c'était
important selon lui de donner de la
visibilité aux français ce que de ce
point de vue là la mission est accomplie
selon vous en tout cas il a essayé de
décrire avec précision ce que serait la
vie quotidienne des françaises et des
français la vie économique et la vie
sociale dans les heures qui viennent
c'est à dire à partir du 28 novembre ont
d'autres termes je pense que il a fait
un effort de précision qui n'était pas
d'habitude
l'exercice auquel il se livrait dans ce
type d'intervention jusqu'à maintenant
où il fixe est plutôt un cap un certain
nombre de grands principes généraux et
où il laissait ensuite à son premier
ministre à son ministre de la santé voit
son ministre de l'économie
le soir disons de d'expliquer plus
précisément quel serait le contenu de
ces grands principes
là en l'occurrence il a voulu faire une
présentation didactique avec un plan
glissant calendrier des objectifs
en fait il a essayé de répondre
vraisemblablement à une attente qui
s'est manifestée en tout cas parmi les
observateurs parmi les opérateurs
économiques dans grande partie de
l'opinion publique pour que le président
de la république porte de manière plus
granulaire en d'autres termes cette
stratégie bon at-il disons performer ça
il est encore un peu trop tôt pour le
dire
jean philippe dugoin clément votre
première impression à vous tout
simplement aussi bien en tant que
citoyen vous êtes plutôt rassuré et
apaisé par ces annonces quel est votre
sentiment ce soir sur les ces annonces
ont le mérite de fixer un calendrier
on a des des français qui ne supporte
plus d'avoir une absence de visibilité
complète on vit depuis le premier
confinement au jour le jour avec une
incapacité
nos concitoyens à se transposer non pas
à dire qu'ils vivent une épreuve mais à
savoir quelles sont les perspectives de
sortie
le mérite de l'allocution du président
de la république aurait été de fixé
trois objectifs calendaire avec toutes
les réserves qu'on peut imaginer en
espérant que effectivement on arrive à
éviter à nouveau confinement une
troisième vague parce que je trouve
quand même assez regrettable là dessus
c'est que les élus locaux dont on
demande temps n'ont pas été écoutés ce
que nous demandions depuis le début de
ce deuxième confinement n'est mise en
place aujourd'hui
et là-dessus j'aurais tendance à vous
dire que de temps perdu pour réouvrir
les commerces
que de temps perdu pour réouvrir les
lieux de culte ou les services à
domicile
autant de choses sur lesquelles on met
aujourd'hui des protocoles qui était
intégralement prenable au même titre que
ce qu'on nous a dit cra dans les jours
qui viennent depuis quinze jours je
crois quand on parle du choc économique
elle président en a parlé auxquelles
nous allons être collectivement
confrontés
j'espère que ces quinze jours trois
semaines de perdues rapport à ce que
préconise et les ihm locaux et bien et
du temps de perdu c'est dommage
alors mieux vaut tard que jamais
j'espère que les dégâts ne seront pas
trop lourd sur ce sujet et que pour
l'avenir notamment sur la deuxième phase
où on écoutera un petit peu plus ses
élus locaux dans leurs demandes
là encore on revient un petit peu en
arrière mais sans avouer qu'on a mis le
curseur trop loin un des mérites du
président ce soir a été de dire qu' il
ya des sujets sur lesquels ils ne
savaient pas parce que personne ne sait
je crois que mérite complet aura été de
lire également que sur certains sujets
et les commerçants soins on est allé
trop loin
on a poussé le curseur trop loin et on a
proposé des solutions qui n'était pas
forcément intégralement adapté noah
benedetti vous partager cette analyse de
jean philippe dugoin clément on a perdu
beaucoup d'âge
je l'a pas oui je la partage pleinement
parce qu'en fait en lui un président de
la république et on sentait que c'était
l'objectif finalement aussi de cette
allocution de ce soir qui a fait le
service après-vente d'une stratégie de
confinement qui a été assez mal comprise
par une grande partie de la population
les élus locaux bien évidemment qui ont
été assez faiblement associés je crois
ou à la production de cette prise de
décision et surtout à sa déclinaison sur
le terrain mais aussi bien évidemment
les acteurs économiques qui se sont
sentis pour un certain nombre d'entre
eux stigmatisé par des décisions qui ne
prenait pas en compte les efforts
sanitaires qu'eux mêmes avaient dix ont
conduit pour rendre leurs commerces tout
à fait fréquentable par les
consommateurs donc il s'agissait pour le
président de la république aussi
d'insister sur finalement le bien fondé
de sa stratégie de confinement une
stratégie de confinement qui force est
de le constater a été quand même moins
bien acceptée par l'opinion publique que
la première stratégie de confinement au
mois de mars donc il y avait aussi cet
objectif vraisemblablement de se
justifier de montrer que les chiffres
étaient au rendez-vous et qu'ils
expliquaient d'une certaine manière la
réussite du dispositif mis en place par
l'exécutif mais entre temps il est clair
que il y à un certain nombre de
questions qui se sont aggravées du fait
de ce confinement sur le plan économique
et sur le plan social
donc aujourd'hui il va falloir
vraisemblablement pour le président de
la république
non seulement c'est ce qu'il a fait
annoncée disons un certain nombre de
nouvelles qui permettent j'aime pas du
tout cette expression mais je l'emploie
à défaut de trouver une autre de
desserrer l'étau
en l'occurrence mais et surtout il va
falloir réussir à convaincre ce qui
n'est pas fait encore malgré tout et
malgré la tension qui était la sienne
que les décisions qui ont été prises de
manière parfois en tout cas un peu
brutal
au mois d'octobre ont été les bourreaux
alors évidemment je me permets pas ce
qu'on va aussi donner la parole à ces
vous êtes de vous vous dites voilà on
desserre l'étau les taux on
al'impression un petit peu de respirer
enfin écoutez monsieur je vous rappelle
crème qu'on est en couvre-feu pendant la
période de noël
si j'ai bien compris au moins jusqu'au
20 janvier à paris en un petit répit le
24 décembre et le 31 janvier et encore
on n'a pas trop le droit de se réunir
donc ces voix là on se demande bien
comment ces fêtes vont se passer mais ya
quand même un couvre-feu de 21h à 7
c'est pas rien quand même en termes de
de restriction des libertés
individuelles jean philippe dugoin
clément oui on est aussi face très
objectivement une situation complètement
hors norme et qu'on adapte les réponses
une situation hors norme c'est pas
forcément quelque chose de profondément
choquant le sujet c'est de savoir où est
ce qu'on va comment est-ce qu'on déploie
les situations et un couvre feu at il un
sens
de manière générale sur tout le
territoire je pense que ce type de
mesures peuvent être parfaitement
adaptés des territoires qui vont être
plus touchées plus mis en situation de
difficulté et peut être complètement
injustifiée ailleurs c'est ce qu'on
avait eue sur le premier confinement ou
n'avaient ni la région parisienne hugh
grant est ce au même niveau que la
bretagne alors qu'on avait des régions
qui étaient extrêmement touchée et
d'autres quasiment pas je pense que on
ne gagnerait probablement aller un petit
peu plus vers de la territorialisation à
faire confiance aux acteurs locaux que
ce soit les acteurs des sandales
déconcentrés de l'état où les acteurs
décentralisée sur des sujets tels que
celui là pour pouvoir tout simplement
l'adapter en termes de toute
responsabilité
tous ensemble ils mais manifestement non
parce qu'on est encore dans un pays qui
est complètement jacobins qui est
complètement centralisateur qui a une
vision extrêmement centralisé quasi
monarchique du pouvoir et la réalité de
se dire que la différenciation
territoriale est une réalité quelque
chose qui culturellement ne passe pas
n'existe pas c'était une des grandes
faiblesses de la réaction de notre pays
face à cette crise président de la
république disait faut qu'on tire
l'école et les conséquences
ce qui a été positif de là où la france
a été capable de répondre positivement
et puis des faiblesses et dans les très
grandes faiblesses de notre pays
aujourd'hui on a cet excès de
centralisation
nous l'avons tous constaté avec un
certain nombre de décisions aberrantes
on aurait pu parler sur le premier
confinement des fermetures de marché
entre autres entre autres et je crois
que ce rapport à une sur centralisation
du pouvoir n'est plus quelque chose
aujourd'hui qui est opérant on le voit
également par rapport aux liens avec les
airs est ce qu'on peut avoir dans les
tricheurs dernier thème que j'aimerais
aborder avec vous messieurs la question
des vaccins évidemment ô combien
important qui a été abordé également par
le président de la république avec cette
information importante en c'est un petit
peu un débat
le vaccin ne sera pas obligatoire en
france un mauvais des ti voilà c'est
pour répondre au scepticisme chez les
français
c'était la meilleure finale en fait
c'est pour répondre oui c'est pour
répondre au scepticisme et surtout pour
essayer j'allais dire presque de donner
un peu d'air dans un contexte qui est
extrêmement contraire on sait très bien
que sur les vaccins aujourd'hui il y à
un climat de défiance qui existent dans
la société française qui est d'ailleurs
une des sociétés où le taux
d'acceptabilité le vis-à-vis des vaccins
est l'un des plus faibles en tout cas en
europe les mêmes voire dans le monde
donc il ne fallait pas prendre une
mesure qu'ils soient perçus encore comme
contraignantes qui relève de la jonction
vous l'avez justement rappelé on est
quand même actuellement dans un moment
où un certain nombre de libertés sont et
de libertés fondamentales sont en tout
cas pour le moins dix ont bousculé du
fait de cette situation sanitaire est de
fait me mettre en place d'une politique
de vaccination sur un vaccin dont on ne
connaît pas encore malgré des espoirs
qu'il suscite
les effets le secondaire me paraîtrait
en tout cas pour le moins délicat donc
là pour le coup le président de la
république a tenu en tout cas d'une
certaine manière à prendre en compte ce
souci d'une partie de l'opinion publique
et à 10 ont annoncé en effet que le
vaccin la vaccination ne serait pas
obligatoire
merci arnaud benedetti d'acteurs en chef
revue politique et parlementaire merci
également à jean philippe dugoin clément
maire udi de mennecy vice président de
la région ile de france en charge de
l'environnement d'avoir réagi donc à
cette allocution et aux nouvelles
annonces des manuels macron